let's roll here okay no Dutch the
reverse Dutch let's try it
also known as the bird is the word okay
Bishop g4 I guess are we gonna see that
let's get on this diagonal before it's
too late okay now that I know I could
get there let's do some other stuff pin
the night let's pin the night you need
to go night in communities increasing my
controller II five should sound like a
broken record now i before e six i think
this is a good idea before my opponent
plays e6 I'm actually having flashbacks
of a queen getting to g3 where this
square or Queen d6 and g3 just like
Queen D 3 and g6 was played so now I'm
gonna chop up the night because what I
get something for that Bishop exchange a
compromised structure I think as a
follow up c4 Knight c3 Knight a4 is a
good idea we're gonna see about that
though oh what's happening here how
about I just go here and get castled
castle before it's too late
I could still run with c4 d3 maybe throw
in a bishop move actually I'd have well
no no no no no I like this pawn push
pawn takes cannot be played don't you do
it because the rook is cooked cooked
rook you'd enter a cooked rook variation
which is not good now d3 I began to
really control a lot of center squares
having a small pawn Center with these
flank pawns up here these bishop pawns
and by the way this right here I don't
know if I
undo them actually I'm liking this room
first so um let me do that I want to
control you five there's still no
context because I have this this right
here has anyone heard of what this
structure refers to our what the name of
this structure is in the twitch chat
I'll maybe be glancing over to see if
somebody got it now this right here
what's happening with this okay grab
this pawn that's a little bit crazy so
probably don't want to do that I just
had a thought of d3 night here and then
Bishop here with the fork but Knight
takes Queen would check no thank you
so instead what about pawn push Knight
here I take Queen takes I take this pawn
that's a little scary
how about d3 no how about how about rook
right here it's a little weird without a
doubt it's a little weird but I'm gonna
do it anyhow this structure I here this
group of pawns I don't know if someone
has already said it in the twitch chat
but it's been referred to as a court
grip and I think it's derived well how
did that come about I think it's because
it's controlling a group of four center
squares we're not the four center
squares are actually yeah the four
center squares in this case it'd be all
four of these Center squares are there's
a grip on all four of those Center
squares I think that's how it's its name
came about so there was no context i
pressure on the knights and now I want
to just finally get this Knight out of
my hair and then follow up with Knight
c3 to a4 so cuz I want ammonia connected
I'm not gonna run after the Jeep unknown
no no I don't want to go after the Jeep
on because my King is gonna come under
some heavy heavy fire now I could
consider pawn push with an ensuing fork
mmm but this seems like a really simple
and good move to run with Knight c3 to
a4 pressure on c5 rook c1 looked to open
up the C file and kill the king
however Knight c3 is there gonna be e5
hmm maybe I should do some calculation
here pawn push I'm gonna do that
actually find push right now what am I
missing
don't know that I'm missing anything I
have coordination here I was seeing some
danger maybe on this file opening up and
then rook takes like some bishop move
but I have it guarded or do I does their
pawn takes pawn takes Bishop takes f4 or
something better not be or I could take
in this direction okay well okay I could
kick this night away shut down that
bishop
not just this right away no let's get
out of their night you need to go I was
fearful of like night here pawn takes
pawn takes rook to this square something
putting pressure on that so now I
finally get developed and this is going
to be a real sensitive point but so is
this pawn here is met with h5 let's not
and say we did
come over here Bishop here I might want
to weasel my Bishop over to f2 just to
take into account this pesky Knight
pesky Knight so pesky Knight you need to
maybe go somewhere else that Queen is
actually short on squares oh I could get
this guy let's come back here I don't
want to get him right away this
structure if you're curious about this
structure and you're wanting to maybe
learn a little bit more than the stuff
I've already shared at this point in
this game there is the one tournament I
posted the five minute fanatics where I
believe I'll elaborate a bit more now
this is a dead game I'm actually getting
that pawn with check the bishop is
obstructing the Queen's view but anyhow
it's a five I think that's how I titled
it on YouTube five minute fanatics and
actually as a follow up I could grab
here and the the Queen's have to come
off and they're ready to take the Queen
with check here so Queen has to go back
there and I'm just up a couple ponds and
I'm not seeing any compensation so I
think it's it's beat here okay the
Queen's come off and then I react to the
threat of my knight how should I react
to that here seems good it's in the
center it's within checking distance
it's facilitating c5 although I guess
any Knight move would be facilitating
that in a play here because I don't like
that Black has thoughts of clamping down
on my structure and I think just a
little bit of a king improvement is good
getting
to f3 in case there's some night move
more king position
I'm ready to play g4 now actually I was
on last move and I'm winning material
although I don't know if I want to take
it yeah actually I do okay they resigned
good game let me back up here let's see
about this backing I don't know about
the decision to deploy that Bishop there
right now I don't know because again
it's just like the exchange of bishops
but I get a I saddle black with the
structural you know structural damage I
have there on the Queen side so I don't
know a few people play this but I think
it's a good move to be testing out and
that is a six you could view it as doing
two things the first and foremost stops
the pin but secondly maybe you want to
expand with b5 later on be something to
look into then I'm not going to be able
to have as much control over this square
maybe only later after first preventing
my Bishop to b5 move maybe then you
could be playing Bishop g4 so anyhow
that's my that's my suggestion because I
think with this resulting pawn structure
I stand better once I get c4 in there
and then just a little bit cautious of
the knight move here and your queen
coming down to mess some stuff up the
Knights gets pushed away and then I'm
threatening a fork I think this in some
sense a lot of this becomes forced and I
think in most maybe if not all cases the
the structure is just it's just
benefiting me and I don't know if
there's a way for black to turn the
tables and get some advantage back so
it's kind of relating back to
the decision of the bishop to play to g4
like this I don't know look into maybe a
six it's different but the very least it
is different